et et je veux dire les parlementaires
politique la question est posée sur la
table alors on va pas sortir de la
polémique politicienne des uns et des
autres c'est pas le sujet ici il y avait
effectivement le sujet qui est la
possibilité c'est comment neutraliser on
a la possibilité de le faire par exemple
pour pour pour pour des délinquants
sexuels et cetera il y a une disposition
spécifique mais qui ne peut pas être
étendue àela il y a eu une proposition
qui a été faite loi pour pouvoir faire
une rétion administrative dans ce
domaine qui n'a pas qui a été BL par le
procel parce que alors doncun vous dit
fautut changer la
constition changer la constitution c'est
quand même une aventure
importante surtout dans dans
l'architecture je veux dire donc
politique actuelle pas qu'on y arrive et
il faut aussi que tout le monde comprend
que une loi de ce genre n'est pas
rétroactive elle peut pas être pour
l'avenir non mais est-ce que pour vous
alors c'est pas rétroactif effectivement
mais est-ce que cette question de la
rétention de sûreté c'est-à-dire que
qu'on puisse continuer à mettre des gens
en prison une fois la PE fa voir voir
alors moi j'ai réfléchi un peu la
question voilà un peu première pour pour
l'excéat parce que je pas dit à personne
je pense qu'on pourrait peut-être al
c'est peut-être faire évoluer euh les
dispositions lgales sur le micas des
mesures donc individuelles de contrôle
administratif de sécurité qui prévoit
déjà des mesures de contraintte
importantes qui VZ même jusqu'au
bracelet électronique dans certaines
conditions valable 3 mois jusque dans la
limite d'un an et je me disais que par
si vous voulez en en repassant un petit
peu par la loi 2017 que vous avez cité
que je connais bien et notamment qui
permet euh des euh des visites
domiciliaires donc des mesures qui sont
très attentatoires à la liberté
individuelle et qui ne peuvent être
ordonné là pour le coup on passe jaune
que par l'autorité judiciaire ou s un
contrôle judiciaire la preuve c'est que
c'est le JLD pourquoi on ne pourrait pas
imaginer donc un dispositif permettant
donc des mesures beaucoup plus
contraignantes en faisant les
vololuemicass du style assignation
résidence voir même rétention
administrative sous contrôle judiciaire
c'est-à-dire avec une autorisation
préalable de jug de la liberté de la
détention pour une durée donnée et avec
un contrôle permanent l'intéressé
pouvant demander au juges la levée de la
mesure ou non là je ne pense pas que le
Conseil cons s opposerait parce que là
pour le coup on serait plus dans un on
aurait un contrôle judiciaire c'est ça
la difficulté ouais mais alors
excusez-mo juste ça c'est possible sans
sans toucher à la constitution c'est une
évolution lé 2017 n'a pas été retoqué
une perquisition c'est quand même une
mesure débouler chez vous à 6h du matin
pour faire il faut il faut il faut qu'il
y ait un mandat juste une observation si
vous me permettez j'ai cru comprendre
aussi que dans le cas de l'attentat de
d'aras le 13 octobre le l'assassin de
Dominique Bernard a fait l'objet d'une
visite domiciliaire la veille de son
passage à l'acte donc ça montre que
aussi que ce ce ce l'ensemble de C ce
même si on a un arsenal qui a été
fortement renforcé et cetera qui qui
donne beaucoup d'outils qui met beaucoup
d'outils à disposition là on voit que
dans les deux des deux attentats qui
viennent de se produire on n' pas
affaire à des loups solitaires des gens
don qui passent à l' sans aucun ça
n'existe plus on est d'accord là ce sont
des fichiers s des gens qui étaient qui
étaient dans les radars et cetera qui
étaient quand même suivis or force de
constater que ça ne fonctionne pas ça
les empêche pas de passer à l'acte donc
il manque il y a bien quelque chose qui
manque alors si vous voulez il y a deux
choses il y a le recueil du
renseignement là c'est important c'est
la capacité que l'on a aujourd'hui et
voilà on l'a déjà renforcé d'avoir
une possibilité de recueillir des
signaux très faibles à basse intensité
très tôt ça c'est crucial et P le le
lien entre les différents services c'est
beaucoup amélioré ces dernières années
vous l'avez dit à plusieurs reprises AB
moi moi j'ai connu c quand j'étais aux
affaires entre guillemet est-ce est-ce
serait pas temps aujourd'hui d'utiliser
par exemple des logiciels de passer à
l'intelligence artificielle pour
interpréter ces signaux faibles que vous
décrivez oui comme vous savez la loi de
2017 autorise précisément l'intelligence
artificielle pas dans des conditions
très particulières dans très encadrées
notamment sur les interceptions
électroniques c'est surtout la DG qui le
fait des moyens et cetera et puis moi je
peux vous dire là que la la les
relations qui existe entre des grands
services notamment les services
américains qui ont des capacités comme
la NSA donc très supérie au nôutre son
de moyens ou les Britanniques et cetera
est très forte il y a la communauté
internationale du renseignement
fonctionne dans ce domaineel
particulièrement très bien mais ce ce
qu'on a un peu du mal à comprendre jeanl
brug peut-être naïvement c'est que ces
gens ils sont repérés par les services
de renseignement ils sont suivis là vous
l'avez dit il y a pas eu de faille dans
le suivi et pourtant il regarde le
disposi ou des dispositifs existant et
et pourtant il passent à l'acte alors
qu'est-ce qui manque est-ce que ce sont
des moyens dans le renseignement ou
est-ce que c'est ailleurs que ça pêche
non mais vous savez attendez la nature
humaine c'est moi moi j'ai vu moi j'ai
quand même une longue expérience c'était
pas à l'époque c'était pas les gens
cétait plus facile parce qu'ils étaient
dans des réseaux structurés et cetera
pas comme aujourd'hui mais vous avez
quand même des gens qui sont le passage
à l'acte est quelque chose de très
individuel il y a un individu tout d'un
coup qui dit je passe salâaujouri et pas
ou pas du tout demain on arrive à un
secteur où effectivement le problème de
la décision est est quelque chose de de
de de très compliqué très personnel euh
très fugace très aléatoire dans alors ce
qu' a c'est qu'on dmine des profils donc
des potentialités ça voilà celui-là il a
des potentialités extrêmes d'un jour ou
l'autre passer à l'acte mais de
déterminer que tel au tel va passer là
demain à 18h à tel endroit non c'est
très compliqué voilà mais ça veut dire
qu'il y a une forme d'impuissance
comment ça veut dire il a une forme
d'impuissance il y a à ce niveau-là sauf
sauf si vous voulez effectivement la
neutralisation très compliquée parce
qu'on peut pas voilà c'est tout des des
méthodes alors c'est vrai que si vous
avez un suivi extrêmement serré plus le
suivi est serré plus les information
plus si vous voulez les les capacités
que l'individu entre guillemets vous
échappe ou passe à l'acte sont plus
faibles c'est incontestable mais mais
euh hormi si vous voulez le le le l'AR
administrative c'est-à dire en fait un
emprisonnement ou une neutralisation
donc dans un dans un milieu clos et
fermé euh je vois pas non le aujourd'hui
l'arsenal alors l'arsenal peut évoluer
mais mais est-ce qu'il faut le faire
évoluer parce que c'est aussi la
question c'est que là on est sur une
ligne de crête entre l'État de droit la
liberté nos libertés et en même temps
assurer la sécurité des citoyens est-ce
qu'il faut faire évaluer est-ce qu'il
faut
AC pe pas moi je veux dire alors parce
que ça làdessus je suis très ferme je me
suis fait insulter sur un plateau peu
importe c'est pas grave mais en tout cas
je pense moi je suis on ne peut pas
renoncer à notre État de droit ça c'est
vraiment fondamental il faut quand même
voir en tout cas les gens d'al-qaïa
parce qu'on a trouvé des documents à une
époque non avait poussé par des
provocations pour pousser un certain
nombre d'État à sortir de l'état de
droit et justement à sortir de notre
argumentation et notre justification
c'est l' objectif des terroristes des
objectifs des terroristes c'est un
objectif donc il faut être très vigilant
alors évidemment dans la classe
politique dans C il y a des gens qui
poussent aux extrêmes et moi je dira non
bon alors d'autant plus d'autant plus
que et là je reviens la France est le
pays en Europe qui est le plus on nous a
suffisamment critiqué la
MT